good morning good afternoon or good
evening wherever you are dialing in from
uh i am jd schramm and i have had the
total privilege
of being a lecturer at the gsb since the
uh
june of 2007. uh i teach a wide range of
elective courses
strategic communication reputation
management thought leadership
i teach a few undergrad seminars and
being on the faculty with the
other lecturers and professors is is
just
one of the greatest privileges in my
life as i looked
at the uh registration list of people
who signed up for today
i thought there were a couple people in
the room who i've had in class
hey welcome back good to see you and a
ton of people that i haven't had the
the chance to meet yet so that's why i
asked everyone and if you've just joined
us
please do this uh to just add to the end
of your name where you're dialing in
from
and your class year you do that by going
to the participant list
find your own name it's probably right
near the top hover over it
you'll see the more click on more and
you'll be able to just append to your
name
don't give up your name but just add to
the end of it as you see many people
have done
and so knowing that we had a lot of
people who
haven't studied at the gsb uh
on the new campus i thought i would dial
in today from the former campus so
behind me you see
uh the gsb as it was uh when many of you
were in school there
and uh for the current students or we've
even at least got one future student on
there
uh this building is no longer a gsb
property but still at stanford
and it's fun to take a trip over there
and and see how they have reclaimed
what used to be what many of us knew as
the gsb
north building the topic today
is avoiding perfection in the pursuit of
mastery
and i love this topic um this is drawn
from work that i've done
over the last 13 years with gsb students
with exec students
and and i'm going to run you through a
couple of frameworks
and a couple of short exercises in small
breakout groups of maybe four
five six fellow alumni um so that you
can
you can not only hear me talk about this
topic
but you can play with this topic a
little bit so
here's the plan that i have for today
first of all i want to talk about
what we mean by mastery and i'm going to
give you
three definitions from three different
brilliant people
okay one from dan pink one from a ted
speaker who i just
really really really like and then my
own but i want to first of all give us a
sense of what we mean by mastery
then i'm going to give you a framework
that i teach in my electives at the gsb
and then give you a chance to apply what
we're talking about
to pursuits that are important to you
now these could be
career pursuits or hobbies or passions
or i noticed many of you are kind of at
that inflection point in your career
where you might be looking for a second
act or a third act or
a fifth fact and so uh give you a chance
to just
explore that in in your own way
so the first definition of mastery that
i really like
comes from dan pink's book drive the
surprising truth about what motivated us
now pink says that there are three
forces
that motivate people if you think of
your own employees if you think of your
own career
you think of your own teenage children
i'm not sure about that one
the first one is autonomy that's the
desire to have
agency to direct our own lives
the second motivating factor is mastery
and he defines that as the desire to get
better and better at something that
matters and then the third thing that
motivates people
is purpose now it's really interesting
is you look at pink's
definitions of what motivates people he
didn't list compensation
he didn't list title he didn't list
reputation he didn't list corner office
talked about being able to direct our
own attention
being able to get better and better at
what we do and have a purpose that
something bigger and larger than
ourselves
and so i want to really focus on
that concept of mastery the desire to
get
better and better at something that
matters
now the second definition that i want to
give you is from sarah lewis
now i invite you to
watch her entire ted talk we're not
going to play it right now because we've
got a very short period of time
but i'll include the link in the
materials that go out
but she has a ted talk from 2014
where she talks about embracing the near
wind
uh to the question that just came up
from
meg no that can't be right i'm gonna
guess miguel
uh the answer is yes you will get all
the slides
and you feel free to take screenshots if
you wish
so sarah lewis in her ted talk she talks
about mastery in this way
mastery is not the same as excellence
it's not the same as success which i see
is an event
a moment in time a label that the world
confers upon you
think of a title think of a degree think
of a certification
mastery is not a commitment to a goal
but to a constant pursuit what gets us
to do this what
gets us to forward thrust more is to
value
the near win how many times have we
designated something a classic a
masterpiece even
when its creator considers it hopelessly
unfinished
riddled with difficulties and flaws in
other words
a near win the pursuit of mastery in
other words is an
ever onward almost lord
grant that i desire more than i
accomplish
michelangelo implored as if to that old
testament god on the sistine chapel
and he himself was the atom with the
finger outstretch
never quite touching god's hand
mastery is the reaching not the arriving
it's the constantly wanting to close
that gap
where you are and where you want to be
mastery is about sacrificing your craft
and not for the sake of crafting your
career
so think about that almost always that
near win
which is a beautiful analogy of archers
as they as they shoot towards the target
uh
on an archery range and and gives great
examples of
of authors and artists who
we consider their work amazing and they
considered it not yet done
not yet finished not yet good enough
embracing that near win
and then i'll give you jd's definition
of mastery
now i'm going to go back to geometry for
just a minute
i'm going to take back take you back to
high school geometry and i want you to
think of what an asymptote is now an
asymptote is where you have a straight
line
and a curve and the curve gets closer
and closer and closer to that straight
line
but never crosses over it if it went
in infinity all the way through the
ceiling all the way to the to the outer
stratosphere
that line and that curve would always
get closer to each other
but never touch so as you think of that
asymptote
think about abilities that you are
gaining
and that pursuit of mastery
for me since my field is communication i
look at approaching
mastery in communication
rather than perfection because
leaders will never achieve perfection
and communication
there is no such thing as a perfect
email or a perfect call or a perfect
meeting
or a perfect slide deck we know as
leaders
we could always have done just a little
bit better
and so my philosophy around mastery and
communication
is that i want to look at everything i
write
everything i say all of my actions to
communicate as a leader and
recognize they could each be just a
little bit better
many olympic athletes and professional
athletes
recognize that the further along in
their career the better and better that
they get
the more coaching that they get rather
than
the less coaching a little league team
of 25 kids may have one or two dads that
are the coaches
where an olympic athlete may have six
coaches just for her pursuit
and so it's that sense of getting better
and better every time we try something
so now i'm not going to ask you to share
this but i want you to take a moment
to reflect and think about when
have you pursued perfection
instead of mastery and what would
mastery look like
instead
when if you tried to do something
perfectly
or if you would have approached it as a
goal to mastery
might have been more fulfilling more
satisfying
more educational
drop this down and you just think about
it in your own mind
but consider where do you wish
you would have pursued mastery instead
what might be possible what might be
possible if we looked at the world
from a lens of mastery rather than
a lens of perfection
and the first resource that i want to
talk about was written by denise
brousseau
she's got a few classmates on the call
here she was mba
i believe class of 93 and she wrote the
book
three or four years ago ready to be a
thought leader
how to increase your influence impact
and success
and for several years she and i
co-taught a class to our mba students
around thought leadership how can we
write
and speak in a way that exudes
greater thought leadership as a way to
improve
digital reputation career advancement
funding a non-profit
funding a startup in her book ready to
be a thought leader
she offers this distinction that's
called
your what if future your what if future
is a single
simple striking description
or image of the future you want to see
an inspiring what if future
can attract followers and galvanize them
to take action
a what if future isn't simply a bumper
sticker or a slogan
it's actually an image of the future you
want to work towards
described in a way that other people can
be a part of that
a thought leader is somebody who has
followers
let me give you a few examples of of
what didn't what denise means
um maria montessori who created
montessori education
asked the question how would the world
change
if we created classrooms where children
are rewarded
for independence of thinking and acting
or to more contemporary level robin
chase who founded zipcar and buzzcar
asked the question what would the world
look like
if we replace the industrial economy
with a collaborative economy a whole
sense of car
sharing finally one more
michael pollan who wrote the book the
omnivore's dilemma
the secrets behind what you eat he posed
the question
what if we thought sustainably about the
food we grow and eat
so that we care equally about people
and planet so now
what i want you to do you just do this
in a notebook a piece of scratch paper
uh you're on your computer if you want
to do it in a document
feel free to do that but i want you to
craft for yourself
what's a possible what if future
a single simple striking description or
image
of the future you want to see
and you don't have to get this perfect
again there is no such thing as
perfection in communication
there is only mastery so what i'm going
to ask that you do now and you can keep
working on your idea of
a what if future anybody who has seen me
teach
knows that almost every workshop i teach
every class i teach the book that i
wrote
everything i do starts with a framework
that i
am in love with and i so wished i would
have created
so first of all any of the folks on the
call
who had mary munter as a communications
instructor at the gsb
i believe she was there
[Music]
until 1976 1978 something like that
um but uh anyone anyone who had
uh mary mentor mary munter as a
communications instructor
uh she went on to the tuck school at
dartmouth
and with her collaborator lynn russell
from columbia
created this simple framework anytime
you have got anything to communicate you
want to think through
what is your aim who is my audience
what is my intent and then and only then
what is the message that i want to
deliver now the biggest mistake that
leaders make
is they jump immediately to the message
they want to share
without slowing down to consider who
needs to hear it
and what's the action that i want them
to take as a result of this
so whether you're speaking or writing
whether you're sending a tweet
or sending a fax yeah there's some young
people on the call who don't know what a
fax is
whether you are holding a meeting making
a phone call
um doing a a town hall meeting with a
hundred people or a one-on-one
performance review with one staff member
slow down before you write or speak and
consider what your aim is
you want to consider in terms of
audience what do i know about this
person are these people
what is the culture either capital c
culture
if it's a global environment how do i
want to communicate effectively with an
asian audience versus a european
audience versus a south american
audience or
what is the small seed culture how is
the culture in payroll
different than the culture and research
and development different than the
culture in business development
so i want to do as much analysis as i
can about the audience
just the simple act of renaming yourself
with your city and class year
gave me some audience analysis
information
to try to make this class more germane
second you've got to know what is your
intent
now i can use interchangeably intent
purpose goal
objective in terms of what we're talking
about those essentially mean the same
thing in this conversation
i like intent for two reasons one
it spells the great acronym aim so i can
remember it
but two intent is not what i
intend to do it's what i want to happen
in the hearts and minds of the people
i'm writing or speaking to
i had an awesome experience a year ago i
got invited
by a gsb alum kylan lundin
who is at qualtrics in salt lake city he
invited me to speak
at their annual qualtrics users group
their qualtric summit
and so i was on the keynote stage with
barack obama
and oprah winfrey and i'm sure when
barack and oprah talk about it they
mentioned me
as well but in oprah's talk
she discussed a early
story early in her career she was doing
an episode
and on the episode it was about
infidelity and she had a man
as a guest who had been unfaithful to
his wife
who was also a guest with his mistress
who was also a guest
and his girlfriend had decided that the
oprah show
was a great place to announce to the
world that she was expecting
i was like wait it's no bro or is this
jerry springer like
what kind of show is this this doesn't
sound like the oprah i know
and she said in that moment she
questioned herself
what is our intent with this show
and she said never again did i do an
episode
where i and my production team couldn't
align around
what is our intention for the audience
in this show
if you're not clear what you want to
cause
buy your email buy your phone call buy
your letter
by your conversation don't have it until
that
intention is clear and i would argue
honorable once you know your audience
and your intent
then and only then do we get to crafting
the message
and we can consider what channel we're
going to use we're going to put it on
tick tock are we going to do it as a
as a fedex are we going to do it as a as
a video that we post
and how are you going to structure that
information
so for anything that you're going to
deliver consider
what is your aim now
many of you are probably familiar with
the slide that's up now
it's the business model canvas it was
used by
the authors who did the business gender
business model generation it's an open
source model that
many many many of our gsb students are
familiar with
because of being entrepreneurs so i took
this and with their permission adapted
it
to what i call the leadership
communication canvas
allegria could you just post the pdf of
that
you don't have to go there right now but
if you want to i've got a pdf of it on
my website
that you can download for free and it's
a
fill out apple it is a pdf which allows
you to fill in
your answers to this now i'm not going
to go through all nine boxes we don't
have time for that in this one hour
workshop
but i'm just gonna talk about three of
the boxes
but my homework assignment for you is
after we're done
go back and consider what you would put
into
the other six boxes but true to the aim
framework
i'm gonna only ask you to think about
three
of the boxes first and foremost clear
over on the right-hand side
audience when you think about your
what-if future
who is the audience or who are the
audiences
that you need to communicate with might
be lawmakers it might be policy makers
it might be parents might be
non-profit leaders it might be at risk
youth
who is the audience or who are the
audiences
that you need to write or speak to to
move your what if future
into being so jot those down somewhere
these next three aspects i am going to
ask you to
share again with you with your small
group so
think about who do i need to reach out
to
to bring about this what if future into
reality
and into possibility
second box i want you to look at is the
one at the bottom right hand side
results what is it that you
intend to achieve results is is our
intention i love the fact that
my graphic designer put in a uh put in a
target in that place but what are the
results that you want to
achieve as a result of sharing
your passion with this audience what do
you want to cause
a fully funded startup a first round of
funding
a change in legislation
a creation of a co-op or an association
or a a consortium
what is the result you want to cause
who is my audience what is my intent
what is it that i want to create
give you a moment to think about a and i
finally go to the bottom left hand box
what is the message that i want to share
with people
now this may be an adaptation of your
what-if future
this may be the reason that we need to
take this action
or the outcome that we want to cause to
reduce pollution or increase civic
engagement whatever that what if future
that you want to to share
briefly what is that message what is
that narrative
this
i'm going to pause for just a little bit
i want to make sure everyone has a
chance to reflect on
their audience their intent and their
message
and here now this may be a slide that
would be really good to photograph
or or a screenshot of i i didn't know
how i could put this into each of the
breakout rooms
but here's now what i want you to go
back and share
with your breakout room and i encourage
that you share it in this way
i'm committed to and then you say your
what if future
um i should have prepared one for this
moment
uh i'm committed to
better resources for people recovering
from a suicide attempt
so that's my what if future
remarkable resources for suicide attempt
survivors
i will communicate with
my local school board and independent
school leaders
to share
the message that there are not enough
resources out there that there's a
gap of resources to cause
the creation of a school curriculum
around recovery from suicide attempt
so that was in imperfect and incomplete
but i want you to think through you've
already crafted your what if future
who do you want to talk to what do you
want to tell them
and what do you want to cause by having
that conversation
any other experiences about coming up
with a what-if future
gail breslow i wondered if you could
share a little bit more again about the
i was getting stuck between the
difference between the
the the you know what if future
statement
and the the message um and if you could
talk a little bit about the distinction
between those two
so that there can be times where your
what if future
and your message are just almost the
same thing
or your what if future may be bigger
and bolder but your message is more
short term or incremental for example
my what a future may be
a planet without climate change
well if that's my message that can be a
little overwhelming because that seems
so
impossible and so my message might be
you know our neighborhood with a smaller
carbon footprint
and so sometimes they should be parallel
sometimes they may be very identical
sometimes they
they it may need to be a part of what
will get us
to that what if future i'm going to go
back for a second to
uh robin uh chase who founded zipcar
her what if future is what would the
world look like if i replace
the industrial economy with a
collaborative economy
that's a pretty big what-if future but
her message was wheels when you want
them
zipcar and so she figured out a message
that
played into that what if future what was
more marketable and was easier for
people to take the action on
does that help gail great
thanks um there's somebody in the chat
box here let me
uh everybody can read it as well
uh joe my what if was what if the
ability to vote and have it count was
equally accessible
to all americans great what if future my
message was
everyone should be able to vote by mail
during covet
yeah that that that is a that is a great
example there
uh joe's one of my former students so i
can give you a little bit of coaching
here
if you can create your message without
the word
should which has a little bit of
making somebody wrong about something if
you could use empower or enable or
create
an active verb that doesn't have that
tone to it it might even be more
enrolling to people who see the world
slightly different
that's a really good future and yeah
people are giving you comments in the in
the comment box on that
jd i have a question for you my name is
dorothy i'm in san francisco
hi george hi thank you so much for
taking the time with us
um i was wondering if you might comment
a little bit on the connection
of this idea of mastery and perfection
that you were describing earlier
with um committing to our what-if
futures and how that interplay
works um for people who are trying to
sort of achieve something
that may seem a little bit daunting yeah
um
i think that with most
bold what-if futures dorothy that that
image of the asymptote
is really good that asymptote is that
what if future
and the curve getting closer to it is my
ability
my success my my uh my activity
moving us towards that what if future so
going back to joe's of of all citizens
being able to vote
safely by mail that's a great future
we may not achieve it a hundred percent
but we get closer and closer to it
if we approach it with this sense of
mastery
rather than with a sense of perfection
many mbas from stanford have
a perfectionist tendency and if we take
that perfectionism
into our what-if futures we can get shut
down
or we can we can we can not be in action
because we could never we could never
achieve it we could never solve it
but if i can make it a little bit better
then i'm moving in that direction
another example from chip heath's book
um
but he talks about um the
finding bright spots that rather than
looking at
all the things that aren't going right
look at the things that are going right
and try to replicate those and he tells
a wonderful story
about a couple who was on a mission
and in this foreign country they were
working on
nutrition for children and rather than
looking at all of the bad things that
were going on they found
the mothers who were creating a
nutritious diet for their children
and they were able to then replicate
that and they
made more progress towards nutrition by
working from the bright spots
then by working against the dark spots
so uh practical tips that you can do
first of all use this group of fellow
alumni
you can use uh the small group of people
who were in your session
you could reach out to people that you
know from your local area or or
that are on the call from the
participant list and
keep building on this what if future and
who you need to talk to about it
i'm going to give you some links to some
gsb videos that are on youtube
great free libraries that can help you
build
your mastery of communication and then
just very simply
anything you have to write or speak in
the next few weeks
try before you do it to craft aim i've
even done aim on like the back of a
program at a
at a at a meeting um that that was
what i wanted to say to the speaker um
when i when i got to go up and talk to
her afterwards
but try to embrace that in everything
that you communicate
and then look at letting go of perfect
in place put mastery where can i pursue
mastery
instead of perfection and then
i really invite you regardless of
whether it's you're starting at the gsb
in january or
you were at your 50-year class reunion
um think about where you can step into
your own
thought leadership i have
an example oh i thought i had an example
at the gsb in the thought leadership
class that denise and i taught for
several years
i was always amazed at how people in
their 20s
actually did have a voice to share and
an example of their thought leadership
just yesterday rex woodbury who's one of
our mba students he'll be
he's a rising second year he posted a
newsletter on linkedin
about tick tock now i'd had no i kept
hearing about tick tock and i kind of
had a sense of it
i read his newsletter and i was
massively informed
because rex chose to step out as a guy
in his 20s
with his knowledge of something that i
didn't know so looking at ways that you
can step into your own thought
leadership
now i've talked about these three books
uh here are
the exact titles this is a slide you
might want to photograph
dan pink's book drive has been out there
for several years
denise brousseau's book which i think is
really good as well as her website which
is thought leadership lab
uh and then the book that i wrote this
year communicate with
mastery uh oh i just happen to have a
copy of it sitting here on my desk
um this is not an infomercial although
my husband says i should put this
this should be my backdrop not not the
dsb
um but i am thrilled with the book that
i was able to publish
uh this january right before covid um
that really looks at
how we teach communication at the gsb uh
for the last 13 years that i've been
there
now i will offer to you if you just go
to my website jdsrom.com there's a
little let's connect
button that'll let you send me an email
and if you do
that i will send you the chapter
on uh creating your what-if future and
doing all nine boxes
of the leadership communication map uh i
won't market to you
uh you don't have to buy the book but if
you just want the chapter that that
supports what we did today uh go to my
website i'm glad to send that to you
also i talked about the two youtube
libraries that uh that i've been
curating
uh the low keynote program which is kind
of similar to uh
ted talks and we have over 200 of those
talks that are up there
almost 3.9 million views
of that library of talks and we have
50 team presentations on communication
lessons
with over six million views and these
two youtube libraries
we've created them since 2012 great
open source free material for you to
build your communication
if you want to watch the lessons or to
see examples of some of our
students now alumni stepping into their
own thought leadership
these are three ted talks that i think
are great on the topic sarah lewis i
read you a little bit of her talk
charlie haversat perfectionism holds us
back
the title says all of it and from ted
med
dr thomas koran our dangerous obsession
with perfectionism
is only getting worse so some great
great items from the ted ted library
to look at um these are just a few
of our 2020 students who have stepped
into thought leadership
michael saltzman around insurance fraud
mike lewis on
when to make a jump in your life and
tammy chen
just blew me away she took a two-minute
talk from my class
put it up on her linkedin profile as an
example of what she was learning at the
gsb
and got thousands of comments and
replays
so finally i am totally right at 10
o'clock
just where i wanted to be i am totally
happy to keep this conversation going
you've got you've got my linkedin my
twitter my email
as well as my website feel free to reach
out i'm glad to jump on a call
i'm glad to do email back and forth uh
may take me a little bit to hit reply as
we're in the summer months but i will do
what i can
and i just really want to thank you um
for what you did
today and the work that you did today
and just remember
seek mastery knowing you will never
achieve perfection in communication but
get better and better with that
thanks for giving us an hour of your
time this morning